mamala visor normally our car tester
montes kirat only wears a fancy jacket
when he's invited to a formal evening
affair but it seemed appropriate for a
car as fancy as the new mercedes-benz
c-class coupe a and says he'll be
telling us more about what his
SmartWatch has to do with the car and
wait 2015 Mercedes added the c300 to its
current c-class generation the coupe a
is the most sporty and elegant version
in the group which includes a sedan a
station wagon and a long wheelbase
version for China it's 15 millimeter
lower suspension coupled with a lower
center of gravity let's the coupe a hug
the road noticeably better
that's the fine montez's first
impression while driving the c-class
coupe a is very good the steering wheel
is easy to hold and transmits a good
feel for the road as is typical of
Mercedes the middle setting is
relatively soft more for stately
cruising than taking tight curves one
binged home yet submitted decent power
to hear vocally some cloven why about
silviana the high rev four-cylinder
turbo engine has nothing to be ashamed
of in the most powerful version the
4-cylinder engine generates 180
kilowatts and takes the c300 from 0 to
100 kilometers an hour in 6 seconds top
speed is electronically locked at 250
kilometers an hour
Mercedes says the coupe a burns 6.8
liters of fuel per 100 kilometers while
emitting 157 grams of co2 the new
c-class coupe a looks very different
from the four-door model a striking
front with its diamond radiator grille
and long hood flows into the flat side
line and then into a high rear
reminiscent of the s-class coupe a
all climate Sivas Mercedes is network
but Montes finds some operations rather
fiddly
for example the SmartWatch is supposed
to be able to enter the destination of
the car sat-nav so he tries telling the
device Malaga Airport you might want to
go there
Clint ammonia in void but the SmartWatch
doesn't respond
let's tell you a philosophy that leap so
Motta's enters the destination directly
into the car system external factors can
influence communication between the
SmartWatch and the vehicle of course
technology freaks will go for this way
of operating a vehicle and everyone else
can operate the instruments in the
old-fashioned way
Manta says he likes the brushed aluminum
trim on the interior side and the
leather upholstery on the door dashboard
that's the thickness the Koopas interior
has a sporty elegantly minimalist look
as in the other c-class versions the
agility selects which offers a selection
of driving modes for different driving
styles
but Montez doesn't like the monitor he
doesn't like it in any of the current
Mercedes models they're just not his
taste
common villains and he says the c-class
coupe a has a serious defect in comfort
when it comes to entering the backseat
of course he doesn't expect it to be as
comfortable in a two-door model as in
the normal c-class but here even has
trouble deciding which leg to put in
first and even though the front seat
moves forward electrically it's still
hard to squeeze past it the next point a
1 meter 75 tall mantis is no giant but
he can't pass his hand between his head
and the ceiling having to sit with your
head bent to the side is hardly a
selling point for adults the back seat
is not suited for longer hauls to top it
off escaping the cramped backseat is
difficult
Martha says his fancy jacket is probably
the only thing that really has
comfortable space in the back seat and
with all this effort he feels too warm
in the SmartWatch is supposed to lock
the car without the key montes takes the
key along just in case when he tries it
out this time the SmartWatch works but
Martha says he plans to stick with the
old method the key